[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today's topic is how similar or French
and Italian well they're actually very
similar they share a lot of common
vocabulary and the grammar is very
similar but in terms of phonology they
are quite different so in their spoken
form they are generally not mutually
intelligible French and Italian are both
Romance languages they've both developed
out of the vulgar latin spoken
throughout the Roman Empire but French
kind of stands out as different from
other Romance languages the historical
land of Gaul is located inside
modern-day France and one theory is that
when the Roman Empire conquered Gaul and
tried to force the local population to
speak Latin they spoke at using Gaulish
speech sounds and that has affected the
phonology at the pronunciation of French
until this day Gaulish was a Celtic
language so that means that there is
some Celtic influence in the French
language specifically in phonology in
any case French and Italian are very
closely related
let's have a look at just how close they
are vocabulary Italian and French are
very similar in terms of vocabulary the
lexical similarity of the two languages
is 89% that means that 89% of the words
used have equivalents or cognates in the
other language that doesn't mean the
words are exactly the same but they are
clearly related some obvious examples
Bonjour Bonjour no interest on interest
on teh Monge Monge re and there are some
less obvious cognates to opet al
Hospital a hora a Kahlua
ok hora shechet Karikari
I think the figure of 89% is probably
true if we include formal literary
vocabulary but in daily conversation it
seems to be a little lower let's look at
these examples materiality of ELISA a
Vienna co-main Cucina tip Roberto un
cafe
necesito Valley's viens avec moi de la
cuisine should the Platonic of it so
here you can see that most of the words
have an equivalent except for of the
words that are in red those ones are
different like the word for here in
Italian it's squeak and in French its EC
and the word for width in Italian it's
cone and in French it's avec the word
for in in Italian it's in and
French it's don't aside from those words
the other words are all basically
equivalent except for a couple of
definite articles which are used
differently I recommend that you pause
the video now and look at the two
sentences along with an English
breakdown and see what you notice about
the equivalence here are another couple
examples anandam in Tecate de entrada in
a negocio de jeremy k a new bleep ah
don't well knows a magazine the
seven-week so again these sentences are
quite similar but a few of the words are
different demon Tecate that means forget
in Italian and hubli a it means forget
in French and again we see the different
words for in the Italian word in and the
French word don't and we see different
words for store the Italian word in the
goat Co and the French word magazine so
again why don't you pause the video and
have a look at the two sentences and see
what you can learn by comparing them so
you can see that in a typical sentence
the majority of vocabulary used is
similar to the vocabulary used in the
other language but not all of it grammar
in French and Italian the word order and
the sentence structure are generally
very similar
here's a simple sentence to show a
similar word order this sentence means I
have a newspaper for the trip yo in
Jordan Ali pedal viaggio Jeon Jo ha nul
por la voyage and you can see that these
sentences are word-for-word translatable
but there are also some grammatical
differences too in French subject
pronouns are consistently used but in
Italian subject pronouns generally
aren't used except for emphasis
so in French you ship out Longley in
Italian you upon lowing lazy but yo is
not usually said so it's just following
glaze it and there's another difference
in pronouns in French the second person
formal and plural pronoun is vous in
Italian the third person pronoun Lai is
used for the second person formal so in
French we'd have boo boo back Lee Toland
mo but in Italian Lapera Lothrop polenta
meant a so the Italian sentence is like
she speaks too slowly but it should be
clear from the context that you are
saying you and not she because you're
talking to someone directly also an
Italian direct object pronouns are also
normally attached to the end of a verb
when it's in the infinitive form in
French we'd have
but in Italian we'd have Eovaldi Oh
comprar low negation is also a little
different in the two languages in French
we'd say Geneva Bangla with no and pop
to show negation but an Italian we'd say
yo non parlo inglese
so in French we have not and pop but in
Italian there's no equivalent of path
those are some little differences but
other major things like the verb tenses
are basically the same French and
Italians share the same 14 verb tenses
of course they're not conjugated exactly
the same but the tenses function in the
same way for example let's look at how
the past tense is formed in French to a
mosaic ELCA shows in Italian - I'm
Manjit ocal cosa this means you ate
something spoken to one person
informally the verb consists of two
parts first the second person singular
form of the word for have and second the
past participle obviously the forms are
different but the way you use them
together to create the past tense is the
same and just as a quick side note
notice how to say something in the two
languages Kalka shows versus qual cosa
French and Italian grammar is very
similar just like the vocabulary is
largely similar pronunciation the
biggest difference between French and
Italian and the one that prevents mutual
intelligibility the most is
pronunciation Italian pronunciation is
mostly phonetic and mirrors the written
words exactly French words are
pronounced differently from the way
they're written and you have to keep
some phonetic rules in mind when
pronouncing words most Italian words end
in a vowel which makes it easy to
pronounce the end of the word in French
there are many consonants that are
usually silent at the end of a word for
example this sentence meaning the
weather is called in Italian favorito in
French l v WA notice that the D sound at
the end of fois is silent another
example is the phrase for white wine in
Italian vino Bianco in French van blown
here the final C is silent so the last
sound we hear is the nasal sound
represented by in van also ends in a
nasal sound the M is not pronounced as a
consonant here instead it nasal eise's
the preceding vowel so rather than van
blown its van blown there are also some
other sounds that are quite different in
French for example the French are it's
not the same as the rolled R that you
would find in Italian in Italian you
produced the R by flapping the tip of
tongue against the roof of your mouth
behind your teeth but the French are as
a guttural are that's produced at the
back of your mouth in Italian party in
French party ax so those final silent
consonants as well as the nasal sounds
at the French are sound those are some
differences with Italian but they're
also some of the things that learners
find challenging about French
pronunciation let's finish by just
breaking down a couple more sentences
and seeing what similarities and
differences we notice here's a sentence
meaning what are your favorite dishes in
Italian quality so nuevos triviality
preferiti in french Callison Ville
Platte playfully so we're by word the
sentence is what are your chloral dishes
plural preferred quality and Ken are
equivalents but notice that the plural
ending is different in Italian it's
often e or a but in French it's a silent
s so Mille and salt are equivalent but
notice that somos ends in a vowel
while song ends in a nasal sound at a
silent T evos 3 and vu are equivalent
but in Italian the definite article is
normally used with a possessive pronoun
like vos tree while in French there's no
definite article Piatti and plop are
equivalent but notice the different
plural endings and notice that words
with I and Italian often have an L in
French we've seen another example of
that Bianco in Italian and Blanc in
French prefer ET and press fi are
obvious equivalents just with different
accent markings and a different ending
now here's one more pair of sentences
but this time I want you to have a look
at them and notice the similarities and
differences without me breaking it down
for you in Italian in Austria Michi
finished kannada plans a day in French
no Sammy finished the designate so I
hope this video has made it clear just
how similar French and Italian really
are the speaker of one of them can
probably learn the other quite easily
and in writing the level of mutual
intelligibility is quite high but
because the cognate words are all a
little bit different and because the
pronunciation of the two languages is so
different the two languages are not
mutually intelligible in their spoken
form but as a learner of Italian my
previous knowledge of French makes a lot
of things in Italian instantly clear to
me so the question of the day
for speakers of French and Italian how
similar do you consider the two
languages to be and to learners up front
an Italian does your knowledge of one of
those languages help you make any sense
of the other or help you understand the
other share your experiences in the
comments down below be sure to follow
Lange focus on Instagram on Twitter and
on Facebook and again thank you to all
of my patreon supporters for continuing
to make this channel possible thank you
for watching and have a nice day
[Music]
you